hey guys welcome to another episode of
my flippin two billion series this is
episode number four we're starting
today's episode is about 85 mils just
price check a year eighty five point six
and we should hopefully break a hundred
mil very soon which I am excited for and
I hope you are enjoying the series if
you do you like the flippin content
don't forget to leave the video a like
always helps out and let's get started
so to start off I'm gonna buy a third
age mage hat which it looks like it
could go from about 10 mil to 10.5 mil
for lucky but we're gonna highball a
little bit here for 10.3 and we're gonna
go for three of them next up we're
looking at the eternal gems items worked
phenomenally quite a few times so if
it's not broke definitely keep doing it
we're gonna try buying it for about six
point two to six point three mil and
hopefully sell for six point five so
we'll toss another flip in for the
eternal gem and maybe do you will not
see me we can afford gonna put it in for
6210 and that will do you maybe five or
six another item we're looking at is he
black di chaps G which I have flipped a
few times in the past actually works
pretty well for a 1 mil item roughly
around that price anyway that's for the
buy it for or 1541 and we'll just pop
them in for 10 and then that will be
back hopefully with some sales didn't
actually end up going with the items
that they didn't come through for some
reason we did end up going with the
zenite bracelet the arcane prayer scroll
and some dragon darts as the dragon
darts we made 7rk on so not too bad in
the prayer scroll 444 kay the last item
is still kind of selling off so we'll go
for that in a minute alright gonna put
some offers in for the team cape i see
if this actually will hire nod will go
forward 20 because we are gonna be gone
and for more than 24 hours so we'll give
that a shot next I'm going to try the
Ale of the Gods which was a favourite of
mine when the master clue rewards came
out but now you're kind of lucky to get
100k margin on it but we'll give it a
try and do 10 of those as well and I
last up I think we're gonna do just a
simple high-volume flip the magic short
bow or long bow I should say sorry and I
will try to buy 15,000 of those not
quite enough money for that 14,000 net
will have to you 13 K I think that is
the buy limit anyway so that kind of
works out
so we finally sold off all these denim
bracelets and we were actually selling
them at loss but then the last one sold
for 11.6 mil so we only actually
profited 300k on those but as I was
gonna lose money so it's actually a good
turn of events any longbows we profited
about two hundred and eighty six K on so
not too bad
and we're still in the process of
selling off the l2 gods but we should
make a fair bit from that as well so
next we're gonna put a massive offering
for the dragon darts because we don't
have much time here so we're just gonna
check something in and so twenty
thousand dragon darts hopefully they
will all buy okay these two flips worked
quite well actually the ale of the Gods
we got eighty one hundred and thirty
eight k margin on and that we got all
ten of those four by the 1.4 mil profit
pretty happy with that and the dragon
darts we got only a 58 GP margin on them
was actually not too bad because we got
15,000 of them I given this about 887 K
profit so we're gonna continue doing the
dragon darts cuz it works very well and
actually flips relatively quickly at
least comparative to my other items so
we'll go do another 13,000 of those next
we're gonna try the gnome scarf kind of
a random item and doesn't trade a lot
but we'll go and maybe buy some of them
cuz it looks like they have about a 100k
margin on them and they're very cheap so
what go do 20 or not and our last step
we're gonna try flipping some serpentine
visages at good margin right now but the
limit is only five there's a little
restrictive in that way we'll go ahead
and just max out as much money as we
have and can you twelve no it will have
to go for 11 that's okay
and we'll be back at tomorrow so fossil
Island coming out pretty soon I decide
to invest in some super combos because
you will need two super combos creating
ultra compost and that would make sense
for them to go up although at the same
time they may not get used as much so
it's kind of just a risk I don't really
know we'll see how it pans out and on
top of that we also did buy ten of the
eternal gems which will hopefully sell
for a moderate profit wow we got twenty
thousand compost already never had that
much next up we're gonna try investing
in a zenite necklace now we're gonna try
to snag it for about ten mil just
because gee trekkers showing a pretty
low price and I guess at worst case
scenario we can just get someone to
enchant it for hustle yeah but yeah
we'll try sniping maybe two of them for
about ten mil
and yeah that works ed next up we're
gonna try the abyssal dagger P and a 5.4
Mills was it's showing on GE tracker but
it worst case scenario I think we can
actually just use a cloth on it to clean
the poison off and sell as a regular
Bissell dagger for a break-even our
profit anyway so if we end up buying
them we should be able to unload them
quickly just by taking the poison off if
we really had to but we'll probably just
invest the rest of our money here
because I can't really think of any
other items to do so do some of these
and hopefully we can confirm it nope I
guess we're doing six then okay so
another successful flip for the eternal
Jim and total we profited 702 Kay on how
the abyssal dagger we actually lost 100k
on
so whatever nothing really gained
nothing harmed too much and we are
continuing to bide these super compost I
think by the time fossil Allen comes
that will probably have 25 to 30 K of
them next up we're gonna do some more
dragon darts another 10,000 of those a
nice consistent money and I really like
actually flipping that item next up
we're gonna do the dragon defender
ornament kit on G tracker let's have a
look again and it's going from 28 64 to
about 29 for six and which is about a
100 K margin maybe yeah than that so
we'll do five of those and next up we're
gonna do the ear rims rope skirt at and
didn't actually check the margin too
much here but we'll go ahead and just do
19 for about one mil unfortunately we
lost money on the dragon darts again
which she'll have 600 k this time so it
might not do this item is frequently
anymore but the defender kits actually
got us a 314 k margin on each one so
that's 1.2 million profits overall we
still profited from this set of flips
yeah but unfortunately the dart is kind
of second now okay we're gonna flip some
our middle pages into the books that
we're doing 20 of these and the margin
is about higher Kate
so we could be lined up to make about
two mil next up we're gonna do some red
chin Chiapas I haven't done this item
very much but we'll try for 20,000 of
these guys head up but that's about 33
mil invest in ditch in Chiapas it's not
too much and next up we're going to do
the gloves of darkness and nice item to
do the darkness says always nice and I
just usually have straight up price
check these items then I will do the
rope top of darkness - why not
at 3:56 in - 3:30 so 26 on each one and
every time we buy that's 260 k that's
not bad we'll do 20 with you 30 not
quite well we'll just use all our money
and leave back in a little while okay
there we go guys we actually managed to
sell everything off he's been a bit of a
mess I admit I had a couple flips just
not totally work out let's start off
with negatives the gloves we actually
lost 88 K on 8 K and each one's like a
huge loss
we tried buying a wyvern edge but it
started crashing more but we actually
lost 50k on it which it could have been
a lot worse to be honest and the super
combos we didn't lose much on them but
we didn't make anything it when they
actually came out the ultra combos onto
the market super combos crashed to like
200 each I don't even know what the hell
was going on so anyway that happened but
we ended up breaking even on that we
profited 300k on the darts 160k on the
gems and a DK on some you longbows so
just a bunch of random flips so anyway
guys I think that's where we're gonna
end it we have about ninety four mil in
the bank now so we made about almost 10
mil this episode again so the next one
won't break a hundred mil finally and
yeah thanks for watching guys and I will
see you in the next episode
[Music]